lots of people skipped c part one
right and so you also skipped see part
two
which is really a shame for you because
there were three
relatively compared to the rest of the
question three relatively easy marks
because you could use part one even if
you hadn't proved it
right so excuse me if i use this as my
basis
right what am i gonna do to all of these
right to get to what they've got with
ease in it
it's a bit weird isn't it
well your connection is this guy
this kind of you should recognize from
part a right and you should know when
you integrate him
you get root three plus one on two very
suspicious
right so or i should say log of root
three plus one on two okay
so what you had to do was at this point
i would write it like this this is part
two
okay you've got this
okay so what i do to everything in the
inequality
is i integrate with respect to theta
because that's what my variable is right
just like here
and i integrate from pi 3 to pi 2
because i know exactly what that would
give me
right all right here we go integrate
this
from pi on 3 to pi on two
with respect to theta do it for that
do it for this one
reduce respect to theta and then do it
to the last one
there you go okay now
it does look rather disgusting except
for the fact that you recognize
these these here they're just constants
so when you integrate them up right i
mean this half you could put out the
front
and this two on root three plus one you
can take out the front right all you end
up with is theta
so this is half theta from pi on three
we'll just finish this
to pi on two this guy over here is going
to be
two on root three plus one theta
pi over three to pi and two now what's
this guy in the middle
we've worked it out before it's a long
term
right
oh i can use that part yes i'll admit it
was harder to see
because it's such a long question you're
like part a i did that like half an hour
ago okay
but but it's got all these these hence
parts to it right
so you've got to constantly look back
exam technique when we say exam
technique this is what we mean
okay so these two here they're just
gonna be pi on six
that's where the pies come from okay so
you've got pi on twelve there oh
pine twelve right over here
you've got or pi on six oh what did i
get when i simplified it out
uh you get this
okay once you um rationalize and all
that kind of thing
and then you still have this log guy in
the middle
but by this point if you got this far
and a couple of you did i think
at this point you see oh i've got all my
pieces the only difference is that
there's
an e there instead so what do you do
you say e to the power of everything
right so you go
e to the power of that should be less
than or equal to e to the power of that
should be less than or equal to e to the
power of that
right so that's what you want it to be
that's what you want it to be
e to the power of log x is x
that's what you get in the middle right
and you've got your e term over here
and your other e term over
oops yeah